a question um pertaining but a little
bit going back to only fans
okay so man
how many bodies is too many bodies for
you to wife a girl
yeah age has to be
you have to give me an
um how old are you i'm 28. you're okay
let's do it girl your age 28. 28.
it has to be below 10.
10. 28.
count below 10. you hear it
okay this is not this is not so much to
do with my age or this is like more me
as a person
um
the way i am and it should know
if she's more than fired and it's too
much how old are you yes i'm 25. and if
if it was the same age as you yeah but
then then again like i said
it's to do with my preferences my
choices
[Laughter]
so why
okay so we're gonna let's say you know
you went 28 year old girl yeah um
bro say it with chess don't be shy bro
nah i'd say 10 10
okay
okay what about what about girls ladies
ladies
do you guys care about that i don't
really care to be honest yeah i don't
really care now
i mean i don't care to an extent if it's
like a guy who's
in more than a hundred oh yeah if it's
crazy yeah yeah so you do care
that they don't wait
that's
for the sake of sleeping with girls
which there are a lot of guys who do
that loads yeah but as long as it's
two figures okay
it um do i what's my number yeah
i don't have a number i don't you don't
care no no i don't care because if i
meet someone and then and we connect and
my personal person i'm not going to
judge you in your past i cannot i can't
be that person in your past because now
we're together and we're moving forward
your past your past but there's certain
names or certain people if you have been
with i might be like oh i can't do that
okay what about you do you care uh i'm
19 so like age range dating wise i
usually go like my age to like i guess
22 free so i would usually say
i don't like numbers doesn't really
matter but like if it's getting to the
point where it's like nearly like 20 or
something that's when i'm more like oh
my god you've
been alive for 19 years and you've done
more than then i'm like
let me like hold the brain so i have i
have some stats for you guys so if a
girl if a girl is a virgin okay she has
an 80 chance of being in a happy
marriage after 10 years so weak
yeah after 10 years she's an 80 chance
so what between 1 and 10. she's not
happy or whatever no she is happy
if a girl waits till she's married to
have sex she has an 80 chance of of
being happy in a marriage after 10 years
definitely and if a girl sleeps with
more than five people what do you think
it drops down to
40 okay 20 wait who i said 40 40 20 like
50.
so 50. so it's 25 percent
if you sleep with more than five people
your chance goes down to 25 chance of
being happy do you know the reasons why
the reason i have a theory
no no so so the reasons why is because
um
basically like a girl wants to marry her
first choice and i think as women we can
all say we can think of a girl
who is dating the new guy but she really
wants the ex
it doesn't matter who she's day and you
we can all think of somebody right it
doesn't matter who she's dating how nice
he's treating her she wants the ex the
more exes there are the more men the new
guy can't live up to
so basically men are frustrated because
girls get ran through in their in their
20s and then in their 30s they're like
oh who's going to put a ring on this now
so you'll say and they're walking away
because half of women over 30 are single
and childless but then yeah i'm
definitely one of those people but um
are you saying because you're you're
it's to do with sex right and not so if
i'm just dating multiple men
it's no issue but the minute i start
sleeping multiple men it becomes an
issue because my thing is i could date
multiple men some could take me out some
that take me out and then i can compare
my my new boyfriend to the ex look after
me in that way
well the the thing is women bond through
sex so we release a hormone that men
don't through sex
so it so it bonds us to them and men
don't release that hormone they bond to
women through quality time i want to say
and loyalty that's that's what men bond
through
but i think the reason that that
percentage would be so high if it's like
say the first guy that you've met yeah
you've only been exposed to sex with one
guy so but i think that's actually all
like sexes i feel like everyone like
with their first whoever you've lost
your virginity
you're telling me you don't remember
this this is something biological yeah
everything with everything we do no
matter whether it's sex whether it's
buying stuff
there's the paradox of choice yeah the
more the more choice a human being has
the less likely you are to be able to
make a proper decision so if you have
three things and you pick one you're
more happy to be happy you're more
likely to be happy with that choice if
you have 24 things no matter how good
those things are you're always going to
think i could have gone for that well i
could have gone for that i could go for
that and that goes for everything
including and girls are
so a guy will go down and looks for sex
but he's never going to be seen in
public with those girls so a lot of
girls that are five and six fives and
sixes are sleeping with sleeping with a
guy that's an eight nine or ten she
thinks she's on she's on his level
she's not he's just sleeping like he's
not gonna be seen in public with you and
so a lot of times a girl can't replace
the guy that she was sleeping with for a
while because she wasn't on his level
and then she asks the next guy to pay
for her mistakes in the past
and she's yeah and she's traumatized
from it because the more people that you
know a girl goes through the more
traumatized she is because the more
social value she loses and it's not even
like social that's true that's true but
what i was talking about is like the
more likely she's gonna have had a bad
breakup or a toxic relationship or get
cheated on and then you have to deal
with it 100
that's why i think they say that men are
judged by the quantity of women they can
get whilst women are judged but the
caliber man they can keep
yeah so they say
[Laughter]
go and speak on it though yeah it's just
so it's it's
so they say i have a question for you
though so do you think when a man has
sex and when a woman has sex that they
both objectively are the same thing do
you know what i honestly cannot speak on
that because i you guys have said
something that you guys said basically
that you know women connect with men
they sleep with and i don't necessarily
do that if every minute i sleep
so i can't necessarily comment on that
because that's not necessarily my norm
my norm is very freeing um
but
i've got my point now but what i want to
say is that
i don't i don't think it's about the sex
but it's the multiple people i feel like
sometimes we really put we really put
emphasis on it being the sex because i i
i've got friends that are virgins and
they're and they're 30-plus and they
still have they've still been through
toxic stuff and other stuff
with men and they are virgins so for my
thing is if we're going
oh yeah i've got friends
when you're my friends you haven't got
like trust me i'm the most freaking
person yeah but what i've realized is
for them their trauma is that they're
not giving up so then they're because of
having sex with men they're now going
through other issues well okay there is
issues that come with being an older
virgin because like the value of a
virgin a virgin it goes with you